durante su primer discurso desde la
promulgación de la polémica reforma
pensional el presidente Emmanuel macron
se dirigió a Francia y aseguró que
aunque entiende la ira y la frustración
debido al aumento de la edad de
jubilación de 62 a 64 años la medida es
necesaria para evitar un déficit por lo
que propuso un pacto social que prometió
revisar en 100 días
el próximo 14 de Julio debería
permitirnos hacer un balance tenemos
ante nosotros 100 días de calma unidad
ambición y acción al servicio de Francia
es nuestro deber y confío confío en que
llegaremos allí
makron reconoció El poder del movimiento
en las calles pero condenó lo que
calificó de extremismo dijo que desde
este martes recibirá las organizaciones
empresariales comerciales y sindicales
para escuchar sus propuestas
Pero eso respondieron que macron no dio
ninguna salida de la crisis y reiteraron
que no negociarán hasta después de la
movilización de rechazo del primero de
mayo el día del trabajador que se espera
sea multitudinaria tras el discurso en
las calles de todo el país escucharon
cacerolazos y se quemaron botes de
basura a manera de protesta improvisada
no está tranquilizando al contrario está
demostrando que se burla de Francia y
los franceses porque aprueba sus
reformas de la noche a la mañana cuando
todo el mundo está en contra
macron agregó que la primera ministra
Elizabeth dará a conocer un plan
detallado para la aplicación de la ley
la próxima semana dentro de los cuales
también se incluirán temas contra la
delincuencia el fraude fiscal y el
control de la inmigración ilegal